healthcare is all about meeting the
needs of a community and data science
can help meet those needs a little
better
specifically when we talk about meeting
the community's needs
what do we mean well there are three
major categories perhaps
the first one is identifying the needs
second it is about optimizing delivery
getting those needs met quickly and
efficiently
and third assessing effectiveness to see
how well you're doing
and see if there's ways that you can
change the services to better meet those
communities needs
let's talk about optimizing delivery and
assessing effectiveness
when it comes to optimizing delivery
there's several aspects that data
science can contribute to
the first one is in terms of just
logistics
for example coordinating the emergency
department functions
so when a person arrives in an emergency
room there's a wide range of tasks to
perform including things like
drawing blood getting x-rays or
ultrasounds obtaining medication
and so on simply determining the order
in which these tasks
should be performed not meaning always
in the same order
but according to what's happening to
this particular person what else is
going on in the er
the time of day determining the order
and matching the staffing the resources
can also make a big difference for
example
some hospitals created a model to
predict patient demand for each category
of lab
tests by time of day and day of week
so it's an optimization model and the
result is that they were
able to reduce average patient wait time
for lab tests
by 75 from one hour to 15 minutes
second there's operating room schedules
the ors in the hospital
are one of the busiest and one of the
most important places in the hospital
they account for sixty percent of
admissions and also sixty percent of the
revenue of the hospital
but in most hospitals the operating
rooms are scheduled by phone calls or
faxes or emails
that makes scheduling slow and it's also
awkward to make changes
for instance when a surgeon ends up not
needing the room for as long as he
anticipated
they are actually also less likely to
make those changes because the process
is awkward
so this is an area that is ripe for tech
for example uc health in colorado went
through a relatively simple process of
creating a smartphone app
that could schedule the operating rooms
and they found that surgeons increased
the number of scheduled blocks that they
released
by nearly fifty percent and did so ten
percent sooner
and that freed up some of the most
valuable resources in the hospital
one of the interesting element of
optimizing delivery is discharge
planning
when a person has received the help they
needed at a hospital and it's time for
them to leave
simple problems like verifying their
insurance or even having a ride home
can slow things down hospitals like
medstar georgetown university hospital
in washington dc
they developed models that help them
predict bottlenecks and discharge as
soon as the patient checks in
this allowed to increase their daily
discharge volume by over 20 percent
and reduce the length of stay that is
the time spent just waiting to get out
by half a day again an immense
improvement in efficiency
that allows the hospital to devote their
resource to other people who need
it as opposed to people who are just
waiting to get out of the building
there is also the matter of assessing
effectiveness
how well is the hospital performing its
functions and can it do so in a way
that's both
more time effective and more cost
effective
well there's several elements to this
one of them
for instance is reducing readmission
hospital visits are expensive and while
it saves money to not keep people there
any longer than they need it really is
problematic and much more expensive
to send somebody out too soon or with
inadequate support
so they end up having to come back again
for the same issue
there's also reducing health problems
for premature babies
for instance at some hospitals
researchers using high frequency
physiological data
such as heart rate and respiration rate
to create algorithms that can predict
when a premature baby is at risk of
infection
and other health complications now
what's really amazing about this
is these algorithms are able to identify
the telltale signs of infection
in changes in their heart rate up 24
hours before the infection takes hold
this allows the hospital time to take
preventive action and potentially save
the life of the newborn
there's also the matter of reducing
travel time for healthcare
depending on where you live you may have
to travel for hours to see
for example a specialist in a rare form
of cancer
or even for something as common as
reproductive health
data science algorithms can help
hospitals in clinics
identity which locations are at greatest
need for specific services
and also determine the schedules that
would best match the availability of the
people who need those services
you can also improve effectiveness by
looking at something like
how well are your program reducing the
waiting time to see health care
professionals
doctors offices are notorious for long
wait times
it would be nice if the patient can come
in and out of there in 15 minutes
the system can use the information that
you had given them previously
that they were able to gather
information passively that the sharing
between
organizations was seamless so that you
didn't have to provide the same
information over and over and over again
and that scheduling could be better
coordinated so that there was less time
waiting in lagging between
all of these things taken together the
ability to identify the places of
greatest need
the ability to coordinate care
effectively the ability to assess
effectiveness
all of these are ways that data science
can help make the provision of health
care more effective and really
more beneficial to the communities that
they serve